versetzt euch mal eine lange reihe okay
ich habe hier irgendeine seltsame seide
aus china ich weiß nicht woher das kommt
weiß nicht was drin ist
sie habe sich jetzt für das heute wieder
leute machen wir es ganz kurz habe ich
mir was bestellt eine sache die ich
lieber nicht hätte bestellen sollen um
zwar irgendwo eine gültige seltsame
black mask aus china was das macht es
war trägt das normalerweise einfach auf
sein gesicht auf letztes bisschen
einwirken zieht dann ab und das macht
die haut irgendwie reingefallen sind
nach black mask guckt dass mir so können
dadurch besser zu stellen das mal
anschauen drauf kwang jae ho adresse
gang so huang qi lot irgendwo aus china
kommt dieses zeug und ich dachte mir
einfach hier ihr wisst ja dass du eine
gewisse motivation auch die youtuber
dann zu werden
deswegen probiert's halt auch mal aus
man solche gesichter wenn sich besser
anstellen anwenden und dann gucken wir
mal wie gut funktioniert und wir gucken
die giftigste ist und ob ich krebs
bekommen
der coole also als erstes
[Musik]
wir sehen hier leute sebastian hat sich
von nächster nicht wusste entfernt damit
bis heute nicht so wehtut hast du sehr
gut gemacht sehr vorausschauend machen
ich die sache ist ich hab natürlich wie
heute überhaupt nichts zu sagen in
meinem eigenen video maxi stimmt und die
black maßen kommt nix mal auch so
langsam sollte man erst mal den ganzen
spaß hier aus vehrte was man sich für
seine behandlung bereit machte sich das
ausmaß schwarze ding
das ist locke giftig alternativ nur von
gonzo hier ciao.de gewonnen wird
so kann man echt eigentlich wunderbar
sachen aus china bestehen das kann
richtig und sollte sich genau so wie du
siehst du das zeug das ist wirklich tief
war und wir beginnen hatte erst mal
nehmen wir die samen verstreuen
leider so setzt das kühle dass wir uns
eine nachricht an alle zukünftigen
freundin die das video sehen können
alter schwede war nicht so richtig
freude mit dem zeug du darfst ja nicht
mehr bewegen sonst ist mein sofa macht
heute fühlt sich so selbst erwartet
hatte hier stehen
es ist so kalt war und das ist für die
verdammte wissenschaft steht die man
sich meine das ist einfach ein traum wie
sich das zeug verteilt wie so ein riesen
maurer irgendwie also eine wand mit
mörtel dies liegt daran dass stein wenn
man das nennen heute ist alles für die
wissenschaft denkt ihr
es ist fucking entertainment denk dir
das hier sind der tement leute
nein es ist fucking forschung machen und
es macht noch kräftig drauf da kommt
nichts
dinger auf meiner schulter mache ich das
jetzt mal in meine lage sein okay ich
habe hier irgendeine seltsame seide aus
china die fakten schwarz ist wie teer
der scheiß der auf der straße ist ich
weiß nicht woher das kommt weiß nicht
was drin ist und max hat natürlich jeder
seite spart max ist so ein satz der so
viel spaß daran mich zu kreieren
deswegen und ich hätte mir so einiges
drauf und werden es müssen alle brücken
team müssen es jetzt wichtig mit wissen
übrigens bewusst
der kleine jack meinl jörg artmann als
chef steht es gerade erst noch 116 kappi
muss geradezu schwindlig aber ich muss
schon okay das ist jetzt mal trocken
ok ich sonst später leute das zeug ist
so arch hängen und es spielt sich
langsam von selbst deswegen machen wir
es einmal test bin ich da unten auch ein
mensch oder wenig wie drohte jetzt schon
zum internet hat
aber hier geht es nur hier aus das ist
irgendwie so ein bisschen erkennt im
moment stimmt nicht aber das ist für
mich einfach sonst wäre jetzt zurück
bänke vor drei tagen gleich abzuwenden
dafür so ankommt fehlen also ein brett
matich tage später sie will ihr p hier
geht's eigentlich wird so schön danach
sein
mein gott ich werde es unglaublich hat
in fucking thron übernehmen in youtube
deutschland besteht ihr was ich meine
alte außen test am meisten dürfen wir
euch schon so eine schwarze farbe auf
und besteht heute schreibt einfach mal
die kommentare das führt sie jetzt
verlust sich an das knistern wechsel
dass das kann nicht sein
dieses hat muss so giftig sein hier
müsste man sich noch an leute nicht mal
dran mega seller oder war an den aber
hat man halt auch ganz viele feine es
keiner gewesen
das ist nämlich bewerber so komischen
scheiß bestellten ausprobiert aber die
große spannende frage dabei ist
eigentlich nicht nur wie ist es jetzt
immer das ab macht sondern auch wie sich
in zehn tagen danach aus wenn ich drei
beide haben fünf arme bestärken mich
denn normalerweise eher weniger alles
klar also erst einmal der beauty
transformationen ihr seht ich bin ein
locker 20 kilo leichter 30 kilo
muskelmasse drauf hat und
selbstverständlich eine polen das ist
alles wirklich mit der hochgiftigen
china maske von amazon deswegen hab ich
euch auf einer beschreibung nicht
verlegen die bekommt er persönlich
vorstellen das video und können
dann abonnieren und hier geht es zur
neuen veröffentlich das geht bei mir
könnte wir haben heute gut gespielt